DC had high hopes for Blue Beetle so why
did it suffer the same Fates as Shazam
Fury of the Gods and bomb Big Time turns
out that timing is everything despite
getting mostly positive reviews from
critics and audiences alike DC's latest
effort Blue Beetle ended up flopping at
the box office while Blue Beetle did
kick Barbie out of the top spot at the
box office after it's been to whopping
four weeks there the film only earned
around 25 million dollars so what kept a
Blue Beetle from being so Buzzy and why
didn't it perform nearly as well as the
studio Executives at DC and Warner
Brothers likely hoped it probably came
down to a few factors for one August is
a tough month to release a huge movie TV
Tropes calls it a dump month and the
back half of the month is usually
reserved for movies that aren't expected
to perform quite as well seeing as
everybody is wrapping up their summer
fun kids are heading back to school or
families are taking one last trip
together so the big releases are
typically preserved for the holiday
season there are of course exceptions to
this rule Guardians of the Galaxy was
released in August of 2014 and became an
immediate hit and like Blue Beetle it
was also the origin story of comic book
characters that had largely been forgot
gotten except by the most Ardent of
readers so what was the difference here
part of it comes down to the marketing
campaign now dearth of major movie stars
and some very very unfortunate timing
where did you go Emma I don't know I I
think I caught a bus in half
Blue Beetle was always a risky movie too
the film is based on a lesser-known
character whose cast doesn't boast any
enormous names with the biggest being
Susan Sarandon it's all frustrating
because sholo Amari duenya has earned
praise for a central performance as
Jaime Reyes but while he's a fan
favorite on COBRA Kai he's not yet a
huge star Marvel was able to get away
with casting people like Tom Hiddleston
and Chris Hemsworth before they became
two of the world's biggest stars however
for a movie to face off against
star-studded flicks like Barbie you
might need to pack a punch slightly
bigger with the casting Blue Beetle also
didn't wage the biggest marketing
campaign to bring Barbie into it again
that movie was simply inescapable this
summer while the average moviegoer
probably wasn't even sure Blue Beetle
was coming out there's another issue
here though blue beetles simply couldn't
have a huge press tour to put its stars
on the map because of the current double
strike between sagatra and the wga
against major studios in order to avoid
crossing the picket line stars can't do
any publicity for past present or future
projects and while the stars of Blue
Beetle have stood strong with sag after
and are also fighting for fair pain
treatment it can't be overlooked that
their timing was absolutely terrible
when it came to publicity frankly DC
hasn't been doing themselves any favors
as of late either Shazam Fury the gods
was a huge flop when it came out in
March and despite star's Zachary Levi's
complaints that nobody's making quality
content anymore that unloved movie
certainly contributed to superhero
fatigue as Marvel moves away from the
one-two punch of Avengers Infinity war
and end game and DC struggles to keep up
the world has gotten more and more
projects that have only produced
diminishing returns things felt
especially dire for DC when the flash
released in the middle of June became
one of Warner Brothers biggest box
office bombs so in a way it feels like
Blue Beetle was set up to fail you're
the Blue Beetle that could use that
Arsenal right about now the truth is
that despite repeatedly strapping on
their wax wings and heading into the
sun's Direction DC hasn't yet reached
Marvel's Heights so a Blue Beetle is
another casualty which is really a shame
a film that put a spotlight on Latino
people and introduced Fresh Faces into
the media landscape is a net positive so
hopefully more people will discover Blue
Beetle with time